so if we have this uh uh update from
forbes
what is behind the us navy's ufo
fusion energy patent now i think when
they say ufo and they show pictures
they're just they're just marketing it
it's brand marketing
and like we used a very similar photo
because it's
it's it's the only way to basically say
like hey here's this technology
it's most reminiscent of ufos
you gotta understand a lot of this talk
about ufos is old talk so what's this
new tech
forbes writes when dr salvatore cesar
paez
an aerospace engineer at the naval air
warfare center aircraft division
filed a patent for a plasma compression
fusion device in 2019
it was either a giant breakthrough or
mad science
according to the patent application the
miniature device could contain
and sustain fusion reactions capable of
generating power in the gigawatt
1 billion watts or 2 terawatt 1 trillion
watts range or more
a large coal plant or mid-sized nuclear
power reactor by comparison produces
energy in the one to two gigawatt range
the revolutionary invention by dr paez
if real
would produce near unlimited clean
energy
from something no larger than a sports
utility vehicle
dr pizza's fusion device is among a
handful of outlandish technologies
dubbed the ufo patents
that have in some shape or form been
pursued by the u.s navy
they're going to mention that this guy
says he's written before with some
skepticism
over dr paez's purported compact fusion
reactor
the physicist appears to have bona fide
credentials including a phd from
carnegie mellon and published some of
his work while much is presumably
classified
he's been employed by by the pentagon
for decades
and this isn't the first patent filed in
his name and all of them appear centered
around what he calls the piezoeffect
dr paez posits that by controlling the
accelerated spin or
vibration of electrically charged matter
high energy electronic electromagnetic
fields
can be produced one proposed use for
such fields is an electromagnetic field
generator
device which would be applied to alter
the trajectory of earth-bound asteroids
over a period of time
while the patent makes clear that such a
device would work only on small
asteroids of under roughly 100 meters
in length or less it isn't hard to grasp
the interest of any defense agency
in providing contingencies for such a
scenario
they say internal inertial mass
reduction device
is one of the most extraordinary patents
this technology suggests manipulation of
quantum field fluctuations
which could reduce a vehicle's inertial
and gravitational mass
allowing it to travel at hitherto unseen
speeds
the reason the speed of light is
something of a universal speed limit is
that mass increases to infinite
as one reaches it demanding infinite
energy to continue moving
the ability to reduce mass could have
incredible implications for the futures
of space travel
only faster than light speeds of travel
would allow the humanity to
allow humanity to venture outside the
solar system
they're going to mention it's got a high
temperature superconductor and last but
not least
a high frequency gravitational wave
generator
now all this sounds like magic to be
compliant i'm gonna read through this
and it just sounds
like science fiction but this guy's got
legit credentials
and what other critics have pointed out
is in order to actually get the patents
there has to be a prototype so in some
fashion this guy's had to have proved
he's got this technology
so what does this mean are we looking at
the greatest scientific mind of our
generation or
is this just some crackpot who made a
bunch of crappy patents and then for
some reason someone's rubber stamped
them
i don't know jeremy so it says right in
there in the article by um
it's tyler rogoway and brett tingley of
thedrive.com
they've been doing a lot of great
reporting on some of these you know
technologies that are being declassified
and stuff um
this one's a particular interest um
thing about the the pays thing right is
what really confuses me is that that
they
i know they've spent more than five
hundred thousand dollars investigating
this that
you know they spent 500 million to build
a railgun for the navy
um if they're really interested in this
technology they're going to be spending
more than a half a million
500 million for a rail gun yes that's
within railgun that's what the railguns
cost
yeah but is that just like the
government wastes money all the time
yeah you know it's it's hard to say
because it's it's
either government is very wasteful as
we've seen with nasa that's
they're buying their rockets from spacex
because the private industry does it
cheaper
um so there's that but there's also
the issue of subject matter experts this
is how darpa
tends to do things i was just reading
the book downstairs on the
the brain you know dark pentagon's brain
which is darpa
and the way they do things is they get
subject matter experts or people who are
looking into these kinds of things and
then they give them funding and for
their research and
that's that's how these projects are
picked up they find guys like pays who
write
he wrote his thesis on this um very
interesting thesis paper on bubble
reactions and
and uh you know his theory of warping
space time and so they they funded him
but
i guaran i know that this is not the
only research that's been done in this
the research on this goes back to um the
mid-1990s to a guy named uh bernard
heisch who worked at caltech university
and he had a contract with lockheed
martin skunk works to um
and wrote a bunch of papers with um hal
put off and
a number of other gentlemen back in the
uh the late
mid 90s on this sort of uh space time
metric warping
uh theory of inertia and of of what mass
is and how to get
mass and momentum and how to alter those
things using um
refractive indexes of materials and and
stuff like that
so there's been some research going on
to this that goes back
quite a ways that's um less talked about
than than sort of this stuff so
let's just get to the brass tacks is
this real do you think it's real
well i don't know that if if it was real
the us navy wouldn't put their goods
right out there for us to see they
wouldn't just patent it and
in fact you know they might change a
couple things in the patent to make the
you know technology inoperable or not
give out secrets we have to look at that
part about you know where it said
they got the patents granted through
warning of similar chinese advances
and when we look at those similar
chinese advances i i sent you guys two
papers in particular um
on that list that i sent you to to to
two of the papers that are written by
chinese universities and a lot of
chinese researchers
on this and it's related to what are
called
optical phenomena and squeeze states um
so they take a parametric a parametric
generator they're oscillated at uh twice
the resonant frequency and it creates
these uh squeezed
states and these so slow down for me
what does that mean so this is this is
uh
this is it what it means is that if we
take a photon plus a photon
um the definement diagram for for that
it annihilates and that's where we get
our graviton from so
we we know that gravity is an
interaction of of photons
and and the way that photons interact
with matter
and that they're trying to change this
through a warping of the refractive
index of
of light in the around these materials
so trying to make stuff float
there's apparently they can make stuff
float and then there's rumors that this
was reverse engineered from
alien technology that the u.s navy has
had kind of this technology for years
they they didn't know how it worked
because it's operating on quantum
principles and quantum mechanics it's
not we can't see it
we can't see it this is something really
i want to say something i was reading
once about ufo technology and about what
would happen if humans actually
discovered a flying saucer in like the
50s
right and they said if you gave i don't
know why they chose this guy christopher
columbus a nuclear submarine and
infinite resources they would never
figure out how to reproduce it
it's an iphone in rome yeah this is the
same idea i remember hearing that kind
of conversation
on the joe rogan podcast with bob lazar
and he was specifically talking about
some of the technological advancements
that we're kind of hinting at here
and what you said i was actually
thinking not the smart part but the part
specifically
about if the us government had such
technology
why would they release it to the public
it would be counter-intuitive for them
to do this especially if they had
something that was
advanced good useful i think this most
likely in my own personal opinion is a
part of
either one a larger psyop against
countries like china
against countries like russia or two a
larger call
for other scientists to come in and say
hey we're working on this this is what
we got
what does the scientific community think
about this what's the reaction can
anyone help us
build this because that's essentially
where they want to go in my opinion
this new kind of star wars kind of like
uh powers and authority whether it's
light speed or lightsabers whatever it
is
we have space especially well they're
talking about
we don't swordfight anymore luke uh well
maybe uh
you never know with technological
advancements we can't even conceive
where the future's going to go
just like christopher columbus couldn't
utilize a nuclear submarine it's the
idea of a cell phone in rome
yeah but they wouldn't be able so so but
if if you had a lightsaber and someone
else had a glock
just shoot the guy or the bullets well
maybe maybe the lightsaber
maybe it's a lightsaber shield again
we're talking about a lot of
hypothetical stuff but when you look at
the us military they're usually far more
advanced than of course
technology that we know of and they
don't release it they keep it as close
to them as they can
because they use it for war sort of the
military it's like higher tier
classified stuff
but but i'll mention there's a funny
scene in the in the movie the men who
stare at goats so luke mentioned the
men's stare at goats
and then i ended up watching the movie
which is more of a comedy than anything
but there's a funny scene where there's
like one dude is talking to his
commanding officer and he's like we
we need to start a psychological or a
psychic
spy unit and he's like why and he's like
well no no no no no no no no no no no no
what he said was russia has started
doing paranormal research and psychic
spying and he's like why
because of our attempted our attempts to
telepathically telepathically
communicate with a submarine and then he
was like
why did we attempt to telepathically
communicate the submarine we didn't
it was a rumor created by the french but
the russians think it's real
and i think the story that it's fake is
a is is a lie so they started doing it
so now we need to start doing it to
counter them because they think we're
doing it so now we're actually going to
do it
and then that's the joke of the movie i
guess and it's not even the military
it's a lot of contractors now
so when you look at you know the
military-industrial complex that is the
pretty much
the key of private enterprise that's
working in a quasi-government way just
like the federal reserve is working with
all the big banks
in this kind of quasi way but but in
reality you know there's also fears of a
lot of this technology being leaked a
lot of this technology being sold to the
highest bidder
especially when it's just in contract
and there were fears of that in the
manhattan project too but now now a
a 12 year old can go and look up how to
make an atomic bomb that doesn't mean
they can have one though
yes of course why can't he because he
needs uranium
you need uh oak ridge you need a uranium
refinery or plant you need
resources and the way that the manhattan
project came about they had hundreds of
thousands of people working on it and
and only
i believe a dozen people knew what was
happening there
a lot of people are saying you know
conspiracies aren't true but but if you
look at the way the manhattan project
which by the way was also forged at the
bohemian grove
the way that was kind of created with so
many people involved
not me all these people majority people
not knowing what they were working on
and building this nuclear weapon and
then we
we have to understand we're moving
towards a new technological era
where we're building something that's
going to be way more powerful than
nuclear weapons that's going to have way
more severe of an impact
and the implications here are severe to
say the least when you're talking about
refractive index and actually so talking
about the warp drive what they're
building would you call it a warp drive
well that's what i'm talking about the
warp drive is a good ver a good word for
it but it's kind of like star trek
you know some people call it
anti-gravity so i'm working with a group
right now
um to try to you know bring these
scientists out and bring more
information out of the out of the
woodwork on this because we look at
what's in the public sphere we got sal
pays and him talking about these u.s
navy patents
but i know for a fact that there is more
research that's been done
into this and i have a huge list of
scientists names who have worked on all
kinds of this stuff
so what we've done is we've kind of
created our conference we we actually
got a hold of all these email lists i've
been tracking down these people for the
past decade
and following a lot of their work
because this is what i've been into is
all this type of research
you know where does darpa go to recruit
their next projects out of
there they go to these conferences where
these phds and these scientists go and
present ideas
and then they pick the best ones to fund
and um that's
so i've kind of like gone over a lot of
that research and we got
actually all those darpa email lists and
we just emailed all those people and we
invited them to our own conference
and we started our own conference this
guy tim ventura
american antigravity.com out in
california he kind of got me into
researching anti-gravity back in like
2002
and and i'm now we're working together
to try to we have a conference where
we're actually bringing
people out of the woodwork to come and
talk about what they worked on because
most of it's declassified now or and
it's becoming so
out there and well known and it has such
great implications for the whole future
of our planet that
you know more people are coming out with
it you mentioned something interesting
before we started the show
that you have this guy dr pace or pius
or how you pronounce it
that he's got a bunch of patents that
are kind of all over the place
like an individual would focus on one
specific thing but he's got a bunch of
different things right
right so we consult subject matter
experts because it's the information's
too voluminous for any one person to
have
just massive knowledge of all this stuff
so we consult like people who are really
into a certain subject
but the fact that he published a nuclear
reactor and this space-time warping
thing
condensed matter physics and nuclear
physics it's kind of kind of
gives a hint that it might be um
technology that the us navy got through
espionage
or some other way right that they have a
secret program building it and they're
using pi s as like the
not the fall guy but basically the
patent funnel leaking it out yeah but i
i would imagine that if this was
developed by
u.s science of some sort they no longer
need it
they've developed something
substantially more powerful and they're
like okay let's give it to the civilians
and then see what they do with it and
then you know they'll
ramp up production and it'll fix things
or whatever using the patent itself
could we replicate
um if you're saying change the
refractive from what i understand we
talked earlier is you have a material
like a spacecraft
uh haul you hit it with acoustic
vibration and then you hit it with a
laser to change the refractive
index of the material there's a lot of
different experiments we're trying a lot
of different theories the problem is
that you know we have we have lot
we have almost too many theories at this
point about how it works and and
we're at this kind of standstill in
physics where we're working with these
you know quantum gravity researchers
guys who are trying to you know work on
unifying
general relativity and quantum field
theory to create an uh a
theory of everything essentially like
stephen wolfram's doing and some of
these other guys uh
garrett leacy and and uh and eric
weinstein
like those guys working on this yeah
he's he's
geometric unity theory right really i've
heard yeah
i don't know he presented a whole thing
to the royal the royal society on this
and um he's had numerous talks with
garrett lee there's a recent one
we're talking about brett weinstein's
brother yeah yeah yeah um
uh i'll come up with the word earlier
polytopes and um
like g it's g like subtle geometries
that make up like the core of our
universe you could look up coccidor
dinkin diagrams if you want to get into
some of the stuff um
or or polyhedra polyhedral combinatorics
okay it's ways that shapes and and
different types of
polygons and things fit together it's
like the subtle innate geometry and they
found that when they when they build
this puzzle of it they create this thing
that very
looks very much like particle physics
and m and m and mimics a lot of these
things but they haven't put all the
pieces together yet
but i want to say that when we do when
we do have a theory of everything
we're going to have anti-gravity we're
going to be able to understand exactly
how gravity works
and so we're going to theory everything
when that allows us to basically build
anything
like if we understand how everything
works we'll know the confines
of the universe we'll be able to just
and that's the thing that they talk
about with uh jack
so jack filet um did he's a scientist
that's been studying you know
um aliens really for for decades now
and he's come out with this new thing
with a guy named dr gary nolan where
they're actually taking pieces of
alleged
roswell material and these alleged alien
materials that people have
recovered or have out there i'm sure
there's people out there with these
materials
and bringing them to laboratories and
analyzing them with this
approach where they can actually like
look at the isotopes
and what he said is that you know
instead of working with you know 100 and
you know 90 90 something elements like
we work within our periodic table they
work with all the isotopes of all these
elements
in between so they're working with like
200 puzzle pieces rather than building
stuff with only 90 pieces what would be
an example of an isotope
so an isotope is just so you have atomic
number
that's what goes up on the periodic
table that's the number of protons in
your nucleus
and that gives you your properties of
the charge and the properties of the
atom
then you have something called neutron
number and the neutrons are kind of
stabilize the nucleus
and you can you can kind of like throw a
couple extra neutrons in and it doesn't
change the charge so it doesn't change
the fundamental
properties of the thing it just makes it
a little bit heavier and when it's a
little bit heavier
it spins its quantum spins are a little
bit more slow and sluggish
and so that kind of affects the like
some of the properties of these things
and there's weird things that have
happened like one one of the examples is
they prove that brain our brains
actually work on quantum
phenomena their quantum phenomenon is
active in our brain because if we give
people
lithium salts but we use a different
isotopic version of lithium
it has a slightly different spin ratio
and it affects people adversely with
their behaviors
and so that proves that there's some
sort some quantum mechanical process in
the brain that's affected by this
different this heavier
spin of the by the quantum behaviors of
these particles and they're even finding
that um
birds are able to tell magnetic north
through a molecule called cryptochrome
that exists inside of their their
retinas it's literally a molecule in
their eye
that sense it's super sensitive to these
differences in the spins
and one side will spin differently in a
magnetic field and that's the molecule
that they
they're using that scientists have
identified birds as using
to tell where magnetic fields are thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 p.m so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you